[MUSIC]
Welcome to Leadership for
Society Reimagining Work Post-COVID.
I'm Brian Lowery, a professor at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
And today we're talking about the gig
economy with Sam Bright Chief product and
Experience Officer at Upwork.
And Melissa Valentine,
professor at Stanford University in
the Management Science and
Engineering Department and
Co-director of the Center for
Work Technology and Organization.
Thank you both.
>> Thank you for having us.
>> Great, so I'm going to jump right in.
And I'm going to start with you, Melissa,
can you define the gig economy for us?
>> Yeah, I think so,
there are a lot of different labels
that are kind of relevant to that.
But I like the definition
that Mary Gray uses,
she's a researcher at Microsoft Research.
And she talks about anytime that you're
using an API, it's like a software call,
anytime you're using
an API to access labor
then you're participating
in the gig economy.
So labor access through an API,
that's how I would define the gig economy.
>> Okay, so labor access through
a certain type of technology, you think?
That's what defines the gig economy,
great.
So Sam, can you tell us about Upwork and
how it intersects with the gig economy?
>> Yeah, so first of all,
thanks for having us.
I think about Upwork, we're a work
marketplace that connects businesses and
highly skilled independent talent.
Many of whom are entrepreneurs or small
business owners who are doing work on
behalf of individuals like you and I, or
all the way up to Fortune 100 companies.
And we provide a solution for
them to build relationships
between clients and freelancers.
We tend the view is much
more relational and
project oriented than
transactional relationships.
Or interactions that are often
the associated with a gig economy
such as taking an Uber ride or having
a handyman or handy person mount a TV.
So from my perspective, anything I think
Upwork and the gig economy while separate,
both fit under this, like broader
umbrella of flexible work models.
And so part of the differentiator is that
the jobs on our platform, have great pay.
They have high quality work because
it's mission critical to businesses.
So we serve everyone from like I mentioned
from one person startups to 30% of
the Fortune 100 are our clients
including the Airbnb and world etc.
And we find the clients use
our platform to connect
with different freelancers
who are highly skilled.
Could be developers that could be
engineering freelancers to proactively
execute major business initiatives.
So I see them as adjacent but separate.
>> Got it and how do you expect
Upwork to evolve moving forward?
So the pandemic has happened,
work is shifting in all sorts of ways.
What do you think is going to
happen in terms of Upwork and
its evolution in this new space.
>> Yeah, well, I think if I take a step
back from Upwork I think it's just taking
a look at what's going on in terms
of society when it comes to work.
I think work as a construct
has been disrupted.
We went through this year and
a half experiment where many folks who had
traditionally believed that work
can only be done a certain way,
tied to certain previous
preconceptions of work.
Everyone was sheltering in place in
many cases and the knowledge economy.
And managers had to adapt
workers have to adapt.
And I think it led to sort of a change and
a re-evaluation in terms
of the perceptions on what
does work actually mean.
Does it need to be connected to a badge,
does it need to be connected to a work
location, does it need to
be connected to a commute.
So if we think about that fundamental
reexamination of work within society.
Then you think about as the backdrop.
Then you think about what Upwork
is providing in terms of being
a place where working get done no
matter where you are no matter,
we have over 10,000 skills so
multiple represented.
So no matter what
particular skill you have,
that gives us a lot of opportunity
to solve customer problems.
And to provide the control and flexibility
that freelancers are looking for
in terms of being able to
work however they want to.
So I see as work continues to evolve
Upwork being at the forefront of that.
And part of what we've been doing over the
past year as we transition from a single
product line company to a multi product
line company is really enabling
freelancers and clients to be able to
get work done however they see fit.
As changing customer
expectations are evolving.
Our aspiration and
our charge is to really lead that charge.
And to, fulfill our vision of being
the place where the world wants to work.
>> That's, there's a lot going on there.
So I'm going to come back, and
ask some questions about that.
But let me turn to you for
a second, Melissa.
I know you've done research
in the gig economy.
How do you see the gig economy now and
where do you see it going as
a function of the pandemic?
>> Yeah, I mean,
I think there's a lot that connects
in with what Sam was just saying.
I think that the pandemic,
culturally made a lot more people
aware of the possibility
of working remotely.
Something that's characteristic
of work done on Upwork and
other platforms like Upwork, is that
a lot of it has been done remotely.
So this is a way of life, it's a way
of working that's more common and
that's more experienced for
people who work on platforms like Upwork.
So now that more companies have
experience with remote work and
can kind of see what it's like and how
much they can get done not in the office.
It I think that it sort of connects
like larger kind of older like
bureaucratic organizations with
the kind of work that's done
on platform based company like Upwork.
I think that the difference and
this is something I would love
to ask Sam about at some point.
I think one thing that I think
where there's kind of a middle area
that hasn't been connected yet
is between large companies.
That have a lot of team based work or
a lot of interdependent work.
We have a lot of complex projects that
involve a lot of different functions and
a lot of different kind of expertise
that's brought together in larger
projects.
So Upwork traditionally
has been more of a market,
it's more like even though they're
very high skilled freelancers
is matching sort of client to
freelancer in more of a market design.
My understanding is that Upwork is
moving into more team based projects and
offering more project based work.
But I think that's going to be something
that people who are interested in the gig
economy are going to be watching for.
Cause there's so much work, there's so
into high value work that's kind of right
there in between market production and
organizational production
if that makes sense.
And I guess I'm seeing with the pandemic
I guess I'm seeing that gap that sort of
space between closing faster.
>> So I'll let Sam respond to
that question in a second but
tell me, why should I well I'm
like remote work so it's fine and
it's also kind of easy given
what I do most of the time.
I have to teach them in person but
otherwise like when I do research I
can be wherever so It works for me.
But tell me why I shouldn't be worried
about the tyranny of remote work.
So all the language is like,
it's going to be great.
There's flexibility but
in that world, there is choice.
But let's imagine that organizations
decide it's cheaper to have remote work,
but I or someone like me or other people
aren't really excited about it, right?
So tell me why I shouldn't be worried
about this shift that happened?
Or better yet, what should I be worried
about when we think about this shift?
>> So
I think it's such a great question, and
this is what I'm seeing a lot of
organizations grapple with right now.
You end up with the remote
work enthusiasts and
then the remote work skeptics and somehow
they have to find a way to work together.
I think what we're seeing is compromise
doesn't really work because it
sort of reproduces what's
hard about both systems.
So if you have a company that has
a culture of more remote work skeptics,
and you end up going more remote and
to make more remote work, work,
you have to do a lot more documentation.
A lot more asynchronous coordination,
and there's a lot of cost to that.
So you really have to invest
heavily into that kind of work.
Alternatively, if you have people who
want a little bit of the flexibility but
are relying much more on real time
collaboration, then there's a whole other
set of coordination costs to get people
into the office at the same time.
So I don't know that I've seen this
kind of solved in a way that
really combines the two.
I'm seeing more sort of like sorting,
people are sort of sorting into,
self selecting into companies that
are solving it one way or the other.
>> And Sam, what do you think about that?
So I know that you have a wide range
of people who are on your platform,
so it's not just low wage workers.
There are people who are technically
very savvy and skilled, but
how should we think about how
far this is going to go, right?
So would you have your job, would you
do your job via this form of work?
>> Yeah, so I think the,
Think a couple things.
I mean, first of all, there are many folks
who probably never considered remote work,
who during the past year and
a half realized that there were benefits
associated with being able to not
have to deal with the commute or
be able to collaborate in different ways.
For me personally,
I have an 18 month old son, and
my son was born at
the height of the pandemic.
And the ability to not be
in a commute every day and
actually be there for
him while he's getting ready or
to just do our night-time routines
is transformative in many regards.
So I do think you have these folks
who are, especially different
generations who are coming to work for
the first time during the moment
where remote work is more of an option,
who are more remote natives.
And so just like digital natives or folks
who are very comfortable with digital
first organizations, I think we're
going to have more remote natives.
I also joined Upwork during a moment
were everything was done remotely.
So I did the entire interview
process I joined Upwork in November,
I did the entire interview
process virtually.
I hadn't met anyone on the leadership
team or on my own staff.
I was sent out a laptop and
was like go off and do things.
And so it was only subsequently,
probably six months in or so,
when the pandemic started to get a bit
better and folks had gotten vaccinated,
and were able to rapidly test that I
was able to go and meet with some of my
colleagues, and meet my boss, and
meet other folks who were on my team.
And it was kind of a unique dynamic,
probably the only time in my life thus far
where people who you've never met
run up and give you a big hug.
because they've been collaborating
with you for many years or not for
many years, but for many months.
So that's a really interesting dynamic,
I think that's at play as well.
I think that remote work's
going to continue to evolve,
and that we're going to keep adapting.
You think about all the different
collaborative tools that have emerged, and
that continue to emerge as people
are learning how to get work done, and
how to triage during these moments.
And I also think that there's
various spaces on the continuum for
companies, right?
Like, for Upwork,
we're choosing to be remote first.
So when our offices in San Francisco,
in Chicago, open next month,
we're still going to have
those physical offices, and
we're going to give people options to
go into those offices as they see fit.
But it's not going to be required.
I'll probably go into the office
every few weeks or so.
And it'll create an opportunity for those
who are looking to collaborate in person
or have those sync points
to be able to engage.
But the one point I want to call out
though is that when we talk about remote
work, some of it is really
predicated around remote from what?
because people have been
working in satellite offices,
have been remote for the entire time.
It's just that up until now,
different leaders have gone and
met with them or they've been able
to fly back to company headquarters.
I think certainly,
geographically distributed companies or
SMBs who have different locations have
always had folks who have been, quote,
unquote, remote from headquarters.
Just now, the question is how much do
you have to be proximate to an office
versus you can work from home as your
office, and still be able to engage and
connect with co-workers along the way?
>> And also, I want a draw distinction,
right, between just pure remote work and
gig work.
And gig,
we can also use the term freelance, right?
Because there's a flexibility, that's
certainly associated with remote, but
there's also flexibility and challenges
associated with being freelance.
So how do you think about the cost and
benefits of the freelance work where
they're not really connected to
the employer in the same kind of ongoing
contractual relationship
that a regular employee is?
How should we think about that
from your perspective, Sam?
>> Yeah, so I think we've
seen an increase in folks who
are interested in freelancing
as part of the pandemic.
I think that we did some research
around a freelance Ford Report.
We found that 12% of the US workforce
began freelancing during the pandemic for
the first time.
Nearly half of Gen Z professionals
are freelancing in some capacity.
And about three quarters of the folks
who have freelanced said they
wouldn't go back.
You couldn't pay them enough money.
They love the control,
on average they have or
the median number of clients that a
freelancer has according to freelancing in
America report that was done in 2020
over a six month period is six clients.
So a lot of the freelancers, you're right,
there's a delta between freelancing and
remote.
Though obviously when folks are remote,
I think they start to
question other assumptions about work and
are like, well, why not try freelancing?
Why not have the flexibility of being full
time at some points, being full time and
moonlighting, being
freelance at some points,
and just kind of evolving
their careers as they see fit?
I think you do see more and
more individuals willing to try out
this mode of work because of
the control that it gives them.
They don't have to put
their eggs in one basket.
They can upskill at their own pace.
They can work for multiple companies, etc.
As they go along.
And freelancing doesn't have
to be something that someone
chooses permanently.
Like there are people who may
decide to freelance for a time and
then become a full time worker again.
And then another time land
to freelancing again,
its just another option for
folks to consider.
>> And Melissa,
our economy is built on the assumption of
full time work with an employer, right?
Not just our economy, but the way our
lives are set up socially, right?
So healthcare and other benefits.
When you think about this
move toward freelance,
what are the concerns you have or what
kind of problems do you see arising and
what would we need to
do to make that viable?
>> Yeah, I appreciate the distinction
that you're making there.
I think that the move to remote has
remote top of mind for a lot of us.
But I think the questions the really
important and profound questions with
the gig economy have to do with
the employment relationship,
just like you're saying.
So previously, we have a structured so
many of our benefits around full
time employment in organizations.
And the United States is a little bit
weird in that regard, we have health
insurance and retired so many things are
structured around full time employment.
So now with I sort of harken
back to what I was saying
at the start with the API as
a software call to labor.
The reason that I want to point to that
because this is bigger than Upwork.
Upwork is kind of amazing for
how long they've been revenue positive for
how long and for
kind of how big they've gotten.
But this gig economies is so
much bigger especially now with API's
sort of connecting into lots of other
data systems that have like large
remote workforces, you can like have
an API call to a pool of doctors.
So Upwork has a lot of software.
They have so many different kinds of
experts, but you could have it to doctors,
to lawyers, to accountants.
I met some MBAs who graduated
from Harvard business school.
And now they have like, you can do
an API to get like a business plan.
So there are so many different kind of
labor pools where you can have this call
to the large Labor Code sort of
like source of project on demand.
So it's that kind of on demand sourcing of
high value work that is kind of driving
the conversation now about the employment
relationship that we're seeing.
So I've interacted with a bunch of
different companies that have set up these
models where you have
some sort of platform.
And then some sort of large labor
force and those freelancers are now,
they had like the way that their
career trajectory looks is different.
The way that their training
once is different,
the way that their social
group looks is different.
So there's so many differences and
how this kind of platform and
network economy looks compared
what we've had in the past.
[CROSSTALK]
>> Go ahead.
I'm sorry, I didn't mean to interrupt.
>> I was just going to agree with you that
I think that the social safety net that
has formed around full time employment
is what people are concerned about.
>> And speaking of that, I want to
ask about your thoughts on prop 22.
If you could explain a little
bit about what that was and
how it played out that'd be really useful.
>> Yeah, so I want to actually just be
clear that I'm not a policy expert,
like a lot of my research and
expertise is on the structuring of work
in the gig economy and in organizations.
So I'm hesitant to sort of speak about
the policy implications of these.
I think the lesson that we
can kind of take from it and
sort of what to walk away
from that question with,
is that the employment classification that
we've used in the past doesn't apply.
It's very complicated to apply
the employment classification that we've
used for
decades to what's going on right now.
Let me just give one small example that's
actually not related to Upwork or Uber,
but I think really highlights
what's sort of at stake here.
So this goes again to
Mary Gray's research.
She's written a book called Ghost Work.
She looks at Amazon Mechanical Turk
which is another platform that sort
of sources to a large labor pool.
And that labor pool is doing
a lot of the work that trains
the datasets that large corporations
are using to train their AI.
So AI products sort of depend on
the Mechanical Turk workforce.
That workforce is less seen and
less visible than Uber or Upwork.
But they have sort of the same issues
of not necessarily having the safety of
full time employment.
So Mechanical Turk workers might come
onto the platform and work for a day.
And they'll do like they'll label images,
for example, to train a dataset.
So we don't have a classification.
We don't have a way of understanding
that kind of employment in our country
right now.
So we don't have a way to
protect those workers.
So what Mary Gray suggests,
and I think this is right, and
I think that prop 22 sort of relates to
this, we need to rethink our employment
classification system and
I'm really much more fundamental way.
>> And what does that look like?
So we're reimagining.
I mean, I won't obviously hold you to it.
But what is that?
What are we trying to accomplish?
What's the goal?
And how would you suggest where would
we start even thinking about it?
>> Yeah, so I really appreciate
her remarks on this and
I can share some of the links
to her writing on this.
But she sort of argues that what we
need first is a cultural change,
a cultural change where we recognize and
make visible the kind of labor that is
powering the digital economy right now.
A lot of those products sort of depend on
the invisibility of this kind of labor.
So the more that we make visible and
kind of value the contributions of all
the people who are working then the more
that we understand the kind of
protections that they might need.
To tie it to what I was saying about
employment classification it's really hard
to say if these are self employed people
part time employed people full time
employed people freelancers entrepreneurs
it sort of defies our historical
understanding of employment.
So, her argument is we
need a culture change.
She makes the analogy to child labor laws,
at some point society was well
that's not something we want to do.
[LAUGH] We don't want to
have child labor laws.
So child labor.
So she suggests that we first need
a cultural change where we are much better
at valuing all of the work that
contributes to the economy right now.
And then based on that, I
don't know if I said you're not going to
hold me to this her argument is that.
So I think one thing that we
as a society are thinking
about is where the benefits come from and
how they get attached.
Is it from companies?
Is it from the government
things like that.
>> Yeah, because I guess one of the
questions I have is who's benefiting right
now from this shift, right?
Is the benefit being shared equally
across different constituents.
So consumers,
people who are doing the work and
then the people who are managing or
running the organizations.
So do we think your from your perspective
using those the benefits that we're
generating are being distributed
equally across those those different
categories
>> I think that's a really insightful
point, I think that's a really good point.
I mean, I would be going off intuition.
I feel like it's an empirical
question that's really important, and
worth kind of looking into.
My understanding of where
value accrues right now,
in a very digital economy,
as sort of owners of data.
Get a lot of value.
So the workers are tagging data and
kind of creating datasets that are then
owned by companies and kind of
producing really valuable data sets.
So I would conjecture that a lot
of the value follows the data.
>> And I'm curious about your
perspective on this in terms of
I'll just focus on the power of
the employees or I guess the workers.
How do you see this way of working
in the freelance and that goes for
Upwork is mostly freelance not necessarily
gig and when we think about Uber or Lyft.
But how is this freelance style of
work affecting worker power right
in their organizations and
the organizations they engage with?
>> Yeah, I think it's a great question.
I think it's redefining access for work.
I think we're seeing companies change
their mind from talent acquisition, which
presumes that you own work or own workers
to town access, which really empowers
workers to not just work with you but
work with multiple companies as needed.
So I actually think that it's a pretty
important shift in terms of providing
more access to that.
I think has the potential to be much more
equitable than prior modes of working.
If you're not dependent
on the old boys network,
if you're not dependent on being two
hours away from a company headquarters,
if you're not dependent on who you know,
or a resume in some cases in order for
you to be able to work and provide for
your family and provide for yourself.
That creates a lot more opportunities
I think for workers to not only get
things done, but build their careers
in ways that suit their lives in
a very different way and be able to
work to live as opposed to live to work.
So I can't claim to be a policy expert or
speak on those plants.
But I can certainly say from
a freelancing perspective,
especially for
highly skilled knowledge work,
like what we found is that the many
other freelancers choose to,
like the choice that they're
afforded through being able to
participate in a freelancing lifestyle.
And in some cases, they get access
to companies that probably wouldn't
have considered them previously or
might not have brought them in through
being able to work with those companies
through a platform such as ours.
An interesting stat too,
we were seeing how it impacts
education as well because we
survey freelancers periodically.
And even though 81% of them say their
college education is useful to the work
they do now, of those with a four year
college degree, about two thirds of them
said that they wish they had
instead obtained a two year degree.
And supplemented their education
with online training so
they could focus on upskilling on the
things that were most interesting to them.
And so it's just a paradigm,
I think a paradigm shift,
I think the social contract
is being rewritten.
And it's giving more power to workers
to decide who and where and how
many companies they want to work with in
ways that we haven't experienced before.
So I think that's pretty exciting.
And probably has the DNI implications
as well, in many real ways.
>> And companies are still pretty powerful
though so I wonder what kind of safeguards
you build in for the people that
do freelance work at Upwork.
How do they make sure their
interests are protected
when they are working
with an organization?
>> Yeah, so, companies, so
freelancers can apply to jobs.
There's multiple ways to work, right.
Freelancers can apply to jobs that
clients have posted on the platform.
They can actually be invited to jobs that
clients that posted on the platform,
and they can get,
they can set their own hourly rates,
how much they're willing to charge.
And fixed project costs can kind of
determine what companies are willing
to to hire them for
the skills that they are producing.
We also have project catalog,
which gives more project oriented work.
So freelancers can actually kind of have
this browse and buy upfront pricing,
say I'm going to design a logo for
X amount of dollars and get two revisions.
And so while they're sleeping,
someone can hire them to do that work
based on browsing their portfolio.
And then we also have talent scout which
actually provides vetting of clients as
well as vetting of talent, so that
talent get that flexibility in terms of
understanding the clients
that they're working for.
So we have a variety of trust and
safety features that we have put in place
to protect both sides in the marketplace.
Talent to make sure they're working with
good clients, and then clients to make
sure they're working with great talent,
and everyone's learning as they go.
So I think it's really important that both
sides of the marketplace are invested in.
And the flexibility for talent to be
able to work however much they want,
with whoever they want to work for,
for however long the duration of time
that they want to work with them is truly
unique when you think about work
as we traditionally thought of it.
>> Yeah, and if I'm someone who's
on Upwork and I have a contract,
and it goes really poorly,
like I'm treated poorly.
What is my recourse?
How do I deal with that if I have
a really terrible experience,
I feel like I'm being mistreated?
>> Yeah, so we have our customer
experience team which I have
the good fortune of getting to
work with quite closely who,
they're parsed to file a case and
say hey, here are the issues.
But also because a lot of the work
is done on our platform and
we have milestones,
we can actually check and see hey,
you both agreed on this work was
good versus not and allows us to be
able to arbitrate in a very fair way for
clients and talent alike.
We have time trackers with variety of
different features that protect both sides
of the marketplace and something goes
wrong then we're there to help support and
get to a speedy resolution.
>> And I'm going to go back to,
I think Melissa had a question for you.
So I'll bring it back and then Melissa
can make sure, keep me honest about it.
But often we have complex
teams in organizations now and
that seems like it'd be difficult to put
together in the kind of freelance style or
the way at least I understand or
I'm envisioning Upwork.
So on the employer side,
if they're using this model,
how do they manage those
complex integrated teams?
>> Yeah, so I guess there's a couple
different dimensions to that.
We have enterprise companies
who use our platform and
they have talent clouds and different
pools of workers who collaborate with
them to get different needs addressed
depending on the hiring manager,
the particular needs of
the hiring manager, right?
So if I'm at Acme Co, I might need
a certain type of work done and
I'll get a set of folks that I'll add to
my virtual talent bench and I'll work with
them over time and someone can also, who's
in another function do the same thing.
But then in addition to individual
freelancers, we also have agencies on our
platform which are effectively sometimes
are completely independent and
in other cases there
are groups of freelancers.
So sometimes we'll have really successful
freelancers on the platform who decide
they want to create an agency and have
multiple freelancers who work with them.
And then clients will engage with that
agency sometimes to hire individual
freelancers or just source of variety of
freelancers for a more complex project.
And so that goes back to my earlier
point about this being in my view, quite
different from gig work because in some
cases these projects are quite complex,
they're expensive, they're over a long
time duration, people are working for
months at a time to be able to I support
the needs of their clients as well but
I think Professor Valentine is
right to nudge that there will
probably be there is increasing demand for
talent tonight.
And not only find each other
within the upper community and
to not only be able to build
their own agencies, but also for
potentially other ways to work, to evolve.
So I think we're paying close attention
to where customers are telling us and
we'll see where things go from there,
>> And my mother said,
you mentioned when you were
talking about gig work,
that upwork is a little bit different
because they've been profitable for while.
They've been doing this for a long time,
they have a certain amount of scale.
But there are other big companies that
are huge who have not been, profitable and
been dependent upon VC money to keep
prices arguably, artificially low.
How do you think about
those companies going for?
What do you expect to happen when those
prices started to go up, as in, for
example, if Uber and Lyft, it appears
that they're starting to go up a bit?
Do you think that's viable long term?
>> So I think the rideshare industry is
also kind of like a specific section
of the gig economy so with Upwork.
So I was at when you were asking
the question I wasn't sure if you
were referring to, I've worked with
companies that are doing things like
software development or
movie animation or things like that.
So I don't know that I actually don't
know that I can comment on the kind of
industry profitability for Uber and Lyft.
I don't know if either of you
have can comment on that.
I don't I know that I can speak to
the ride ride hailing industry.
>> Yeah, I guess I just wonder,
is the gig economy in our current
social context, is it viable?
That's kind of what, we don't have to call
it Uber or Lyft, but the gig economy.
because I would say I'm going to
separate Upwork a little bit right?
They're not in the same kind of
category as some of the,
what I think most of us have
direct experience with and
there's a variety of ways that we
engage with gig work a lot of us.
I'm wondering do you think in
the current social political
space that the way gig work is
set up is that it's in your mind
is that viable
>> I see yeah so I think there
are different trends that are pretending
that this will be like a larger,
part of the economy like
a larger way of working.
I think that the gig economy is part of it
the gig economy as we currently understand
it, where you have startups that
are creating platforms that connected with
Networks of laborers like labor.
That's part of it.
But what I was describing before with,
actually,
I can point to the research by Jerry
Davis, who's a professor at Michigan.
And his research looks
at the population of
public corporations in
the United States over time.
And he's shown that the number of public
corporations in the US is shrinking.
The number and like the population and
the size of public
corporations is just smaller.
He gives an example of when Circuit City
in 2009 Circuit City liquidated.
They had I think it was
like 30,000 employees and
then someone bought them and
then they became just a website so
now they're just like a website where
you're fulfilling orders for electronics.
So instead of having a large set of full
time employees now you have like a website
The site basically where people
are able to buy electronics and
what made that possible was an API, right?
So we have APIs that are basically
connecting different parts of companies.
You can now have an API to marketing.
You can have an API to HR and
API to accounting.
So instead of needing to have a large
corporation that has each of these
functions.
You can now sort of have this small
lean staff maybe that connects to
different functions that you'll
spin up from time to time.
So I'm hearing a lot of discussion
about how there might be kind of small
core to accompany and
then a lot of kind of contingent labor
of some sort in the periphery around.
So I think we're seeing that that seems
likely it's not a question of whether it's
profitable.
It's kind of it's what's
happening right now I think.
>> I see.
And do you see that as
exacerbating inequality?
So you have like this core of people
who are in the company in these and
then the I don't,
I'll call it the periphery around or
the people who were contract with around.
Do you imagine like let's say this
is you're out in the workforce,
do you want to be the contractor or
do you want to be central?
>> Right exactly,
it's a great [LAUGH] question.
Yeah, I actually I have
a story about that.
So my research collaboration team and
I did a study where we used
Upwork to create flash teams.
We just had a platform that basically
pulled it together teams from Upwork and
they work together.
It was published in the New York Times and
we got a little bit of attention for it.
And we were sort of engaging
with people on Twitter about it.
And somebody tagged me on it and
they were like, if this is so great,
why are you trying to get
tenure at Stanford University?
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] Great question, great question.
>> [LAUGH] I just I've told this story
like, [LAUGH] every day
since that's how I respond.
It is was such a last question.
Question, it was really important.
It's really an important question.
Yeah, and I think there's a lesson to be
drawn from it because what I love about my
job is actually everything that
Sam was describing, like I have so
much flexibility to pick my projects.
And I have, like guaranteed
pay like lifelong employment,
I have health insurance I have benefits.
So I think people who are working in
the gig economy these like we all I guess
society needs to be careful about all the
language that we use about flexibility.
When we're speaking from a place where we
have a lot of benefits kind of built in
around everything that we're doing.
Otherwise, it is very likely to exacerbate
inequality as you're saying, yeah.
>> And Sam, what do you think are the
limits of the kind of freelance work that
Upwork supports?
Right so it's,
I don't assume that an organization
is going to become a fully freelance.
I don't even know what that would mean but
fully freelance.
>> Yeah, so I guess a couple thoughts.
I think it's probably interesting
to ponder how the gig economy and
the creator economy
are sort of interfacing.
And if you think about a lot of
the entrepreneurs on the Upwork platform,
who are freelancers,
like many of them are creators and
they see themselves with
a very entrepreneurial.
Then in terms of delivering products and
services that then form their portfolios
and then drive additional work and
higher dollars per hour or
higher fixed project prices.
I think that's an interesting,
interesting sync point.
But I'm continuously surprised
by not only the breadth of
skills that are on the platform.
But then also how many companies
are realizing areas that
they thought may not have been
able to support hybrid work
are support freelancing that they
find ways for that to occur.
So I expect we're going to see more and
more of that over time now,
we're primarily focused on knowledge work.
So I think there are categories where
we are not, you know, present or
for whatever reason it's we're
not the right solution for but.
We have people who hire and
get hire paralegals,
folks who have accounts and we have.
See customer support,
team members and you pick the arena.
We have people who provide music
lessons through project catalog.
So you pick the arena,
knowledge work that can be done,
virtually or even done virtually
even if the person on the other side
of the contract is your next door
neighbor and you don't know it.
Is something that Upwork supports.
And so I'm going to be really interested
to see how those vectors evolve over time.
But it's going to be completely driven by
the demand that we see from workers and
as workers want to have more
flexibility in their lives.
And don't want to go back into
the office and drive two hours each day
to laugh at jokes from their boss
they never thought were funny.
I think you'll see more and
more people choose freelancing and
categories that we may not
even be aware of right now.
>> I'm still curious about the limit.
So let's say I'm a CEO.
Our company's completely virtual,
everybody's virtual.
Why don't I need a CTO or
a chief product officer,
why don't I just get freelance
people doing that with that?
Is that possible?
Is that plausible?
Would that be a good idea
from your perspective?
>> Yeah, so I have heard about companies
who are using fractional executives for
that very reason.
Sometimes they will stand up
organizations with a series of C-suite
leaders who will split their time across
three or four different companies.
So people are experimenting
with that even today.
How that will evolve over time and
what the pros and
cons of that will be,
I'm not sure I can speak to that.
But I do think that the general trend of
us innovating with work which has had this
sort of really, I think universally shared
in many respects, set of characteristics.
Now that remote work is
causing us to question things,
probably makes us really challenge whether
or not some of the assumptions we've had,
across the board, including that
use case are truly constraints.
>> May I build on that Brian?
>> Of course, yes.
>> It's just another story, so
I've given the flash teams talk to
executive audiences for
the past five years and
I think that their question is what
you're asking, what's the limit of this?
So I'll present and I'll be like, flash
teams you can build this new team and
it will help.
And at the start, everyone was like,
wow that's so cool.
And then increasingly the question
that I get, starting three years ago,
the question I started to get was always
like, yes, the problem is not access,
it's integration.
The problem is always integration.
I think people are starting to buy into
the idea that you can kind of access a lot
of talent quickly, but
integrating what they build is the real
challenge at this point I think.
>> So you think that is a limit right now?
>> Yeah.
>> So I was wondering if all
this is making me think,
is the corporate structure we have,
or at least the way we think
about organizations, is that are you
all suggesting that's outdated?
Or that we're going to move beyond
that in the foreseeable future?
I mean, because Sam, that's what I
hear you saying that is a distinct
possibility and I'm curious Melissa, and
Sam, you can agree or not agree with that.
I'm curious but Melissa,
what do you think about that?
>> This is the question that I'm
glad that you posed it like that,
this is the question that I think about,
and talk about with people all the time.
And I think we have a classic theory
of the firm, the reason that we have
organizations is because hierarchy has
just particular coordination properties.
It's easier to integrate, there's a little
bit easier to have accountability and
to integrate complex work using hierarchy,
that's like classic economic theory,
right?
So I haven't seen anything
that challenges that idea.
I think this idea of having a core and
periphery is probably where we're headed.
But having some sort of firm at the center
because it coordinates complex work,
that's just a structure that
coordinates complex work differently.
And there's actually a great paper
by some professors at MIT that talk
about how accountability sort of
accrues within a hierarchy differently.
So society sort of depends on
people to point to something and
be like,
that company is accountable for this.
So accountability and coordination
are sort of served by hierarchy.
And that's what the firm does.
So that's kind of what I'm thinking
about right now in terms of is how far
this will go.
>> Great, and Sam,
you have the last word on that.
>> Well,
I think that we've already seen how work
gets done in corporations
change quite a bit.
Folks who manage by walking around or
who were used to FaceTime or
what have you, all those things
had to evolve during the pandemic.
And then people started to adapt the way
that they managed in very different
ways, right?
Like weekly Slack updates started too and
virtual all hands and
virtual happy hours and Zoom calls and
all sorts of different dynamics
started to come to bear.
I think that there are parallel tracks
of innovation that are underway.
I think folks are systematically trying
to build tools that will reinvent and
reinvigorate the workforce.
And in parallel you have these
trends of the remote natives and
remote work underway that I think
are going to challenge these assumptions.
I do see value for the concept of a firm.
But I think how that is constructed,
configured and even the work or
composition of it over time, is we're
going to be experimenting with it,
I think as a society for a little while.
And that's incredibly exciting
because this is a frontier
of innovation that I think there's
probably being less room for
experimentation that is
now being challenged.
>> I mean, I agree with both of you
that we're clearly going to see a lot of
experimentation and
it's going to be interesting to
see how it all evolves overtime.
So thank you both very much for
talking with me today about it.
>> Thanks so much.
>> All right, so next week I'll discuss
the role of business, philanthropy and
government to provide
safety to the people.
We'll talk to Aisha Nyandoro,
CEO of Springboard to Opportunities,
and Dr. William Spriggs chief
economist for the AFL CIO.
Thanks, see you then.
[MUSIC]